[Aplausos]
tres pasos para llegar a la plenitud
antes de empezar les quiero contar
rapidísimo la historia atrás del título
y es que yo soy una fiel creyente de que
hay que compartir lo que a ti te hubiera
encantado que te compartieran típico que
te dicen escribe libro que te hubiera
encantado leer pues yo decidí darle a
ted talks que a mí me hubiera encantado
escuchar y para darles un poquito más de
contexto les cuento cómo es que yo
llegué a este tema a ver siempre ha sido
una persona súper reflexiva le doy mil
vueltas a las cosas creo que es parte de
quién soy y como a los 15 y 16 años más
o menos me empecé a dar cuenta que
cuando buscaba algo realmente estaba
buscando algo muchísimo más profundo de
lo que pensaba que buscaba ya estoy aquí
pares de trabalenguas pero les voy a
poner un ejemplo para darme entender
mejor
al principio de la pandemia porque
obviamente me sigue pasando me obsesione
con el ipad pero ok pero mal yo estudio
de diseño gráfico entonces dije guau voy
a poder dibujar cosas increíbles
necesito el ipad pero vi como 55.000
vídeos en youtube y no sé cómo pero
consiguió el dinero para comprarme lo me
lo compro y de verdad no saben o sea no
sé cómo explicarles el vacío que sentí
después de comprarlo pues hay a ver me
llegó y lo disfruté y me encantó abrirlo
y amo mi ipad a la fecha pero justamente
yo estaba buscando algo muchísimo más
profundo de like que el ipad yo pensaba
que cuando tuviera ese ipad ahí iba a
ser feliz
y así me empecé a dar cuenta que todo lo
que hacía
al final estaba buscando una felicidad
de fondo
y encontré en mí una sed profunda de
felicidad profunda o saber un sola
palabra sed porque justamente ya no era
un me gustaría ser feliz estaría que
algún día en mi vida llegará a ser feliz
era una necesidad necesito ser feliz
cómo le hago y como cualquier persona de
16 17 años maybe que tienes en ese
momento mi primer fuente información fue
google y me metí y empecé qué es la
felicidad cómo ser feliz en mente a
youtube conferencias ted talks
obviamente libros fueron como dos años
de mi vida en los que de verdad yo
consumía consumida y consumía contenido
y hubo dos grandes descubrimientos no
después de todo este tiempo de
investigación el primer gran
descubrimiento fue que realmente no
estaba buscando la felicidad
y a ver ahí me gusta más el término
happiness en inglés que justamente viene
de la palabra happen que significa pasa
y es que justamente la felicidad es eso
circunstancial ahorita yo estoy súper
feliz porque estoy dando un atento aquí
es el sueño de mi vida pero si mañana se
me muere un ser querido no quiero estar
así de feliz en el funeral sería ilógico
porque la felicidad justamente se ve así
subidas y bajadas una línea en picos y
si quieres ser más feliz pues al final
propicia los momentos que te van a dar
felicidad hace ejercicio sal de viaje
estar con tus amigas
y todo cosas súper buenas pero así como
hay en la vida siempre va a haber down
siempre haber problemas siempre va haber
retos se prevé el sufrimiento
es la felicidad se ve así no picos pero
por otro lado está la plenitud que al
contrario de la felicidad se ve más bien
como una línea recta y se experimenta
como una paz interior y puedes estar en
el mejor momento de tu vida siendo la
persona más linda del mundo
pero también en un muy mal momento de tu
vida y seguir con esta misma paz ya ver
suena increíble la palabra plenitud pero
qué significa realmente ser pleno
a ver la palabra en sí significa
totalidad o está relleno y para eso es
que traigo los vasos porque a mí me
ayuda a explicarme mejor tenemos este
vaso y al final está la mitad está lleno
de agua imagínate que tú eres si este
vaso muchas veces vivimos así pero de
verdad estamos llamados a llegar hasta
acá tenemos la capacidad de llegar hasta
acá
si me preguntan a mí mi definición de
plenitud de ser tú mismo al 100% en
todos los aspectos de tu vida en la
parte física en la parte intelectual en
la parte espiritual en la parte social
tu personalidad al 100% todo lo que eres
tú como persona exponenciado al 100%
es mi primer gran descubrimiento fuese
que yo no estaba buscando la felicidad
estaba buscando la plenitud mi segundo
gran descubrimiento es que yo no era la
única de verdad entre más me metía y más
investigaba más me daba cuenta la sed
que existía en el mundo de plenitud
es impresionante que todos aquí podemos
decir que de verdad todos queremos una
vida al 100 mi vida no la típica frase
de igual hay varios breeding queremos
vivir no solamente respirar
y antes de empezar con los tres pasos
quiero aclarar que de verdad yo no vengo
aquí como sofía carreón con el trofeo de
la plenitud a decirles sigan mis pasos
porque les mentiría yo sigo en ese
camino a la plenitud pero les vengo a
compartir las cosas que a mí me han
ayudado a crecer en plenitud no entonces
el primer paso conoce tu vaso conoce tu
recipiente y por eso es que traigo
diferentes recipientes a mí me encanta
el tema de que somos únicos y no sé si
se han puesto a pensar en la huella
digital
santi verdad nadie nunca en la historia
de la humanidad ha tenido ni va a tener
tu huella digital
imagínate si el circulito en la punta de
tu dedo es único lo único que eres tú
como persona y así como tú eres único tu
plenitud va a ser única
hay que conocer de que es tu régimen de
que este recipiente de qué tamaño de qué
color de qué forma
con que se llena porque podríamos
intentar llenar este caballito de agua
pura y perdón pero de verdad sería el
vaso más inútil del mundo intenta comer
una comida entera
con esto cuántos tendremos que servirnos
porque para esto no fue pensado para eso
no fue creado no entonces es muy
necesario conocernos como nos conocemos
yo creo que una de las mejores maneras
es cuestionándonos
les cuento una historia una anécdota mía
no hace como dos años empecé un proceso
psicológico que hiciera la psicóloga y
me acuerdo que hubo como un mes en mi
vida donde de verdad todo era cristos
ayuda a la persona más desanimada del
mundo apática me está costando mucho a
nivel universidad no mi carrera me
estaba costando mucho y llegué con mi
psicóloga y le dije es que de verdad no
sé qué hacer estoy así y me pregunta a
sofía porque estudias lo que estudias yo
en ese momento estaba estudiando diseño
industrial
y le dije pues empecé a estudiar diseño
industrial porque quería tener mi
empresa con mis productos pero ya no sé
si es lo que quiero y me dijo a ver
sofía te cambió la pregunta por qué
estudias
no saben lo que me impactó esa pregunta
porque no sé por qué contestarle creo
que para mí fue un por qué era lo que
seguía no estás en secundaria qué pasa
te gradúas toca prepara te gradúas y que
toca en la universidad y busca una
carrera más o menos que vaya con tus
dones y así
y ya y lo que más me quede de esa
conversación que tuve fue de verdad la
inconsciencia con la que muchas veces
vivimos vamos por la vida ojos sin
tiempo sin tiempo para nada porque todo
el mundo tiene 55 mil cosas que hacer
pero ni siquiera sabes que estás
haciendo porque lo estás haciendo es
fuertísimo que en un mundo tan lleno de
respuestas
porque puedes tener la respuesta que
quiera la información que quieras al
alcance de un clic en un mundo tan lleno
de respuestas que pasaría 7 pregunta
ahorita quién eres
a dónde vas qué buscas
son preguntas que más cuesta
respondernos y que muchas veces no nos
damos el tiempo para respondernos creo
yo porque hay miedo existe un miedo a
conocernos a enfrentarnos porque
justamente conocernos y enfrentarnos
implica aceptar ese es el segundo paso
primer paso cuestionarte para conocerte
segundo paso aceptar aceptar que primero
que nada a ver si el vaso está la mitad
lleno significa que hay un vacío
creo que eso es lo primero que tenemos
que aceptar que hay un vacío que tal vez
no soy tan feliz como me gustaría hacer
o cómo le demuestro al mundo que soy
y es que no sé por qué es tan importante
aceptar porque hasta que no aceptes que
hay un vacío no vas a poder empezarlo a
llenar
aceptar
que hay un vacío y aceptar tu forma
porque me acuerdo en este proceso mío
hubo un momento donde me empecé a sentir
súper culpable porque inicia porque no
soy plena tengo una familia increíble
tengo amigas increíbles está en una
universidad que me encanta una religión
que amo porque siento que tiene que
haber más
y te sientes culpable porque típico que
te comparas con el niñito de áfrica que
tiene muchísimo menos que tú y es mucho
más feliz que tú dices
media hora de conformar con lo que tengo
y ahí como nos encanta compararnos y voy
a volver al al tema en los recipientes
no imaginémonos que el limite o de
áfrica es este caballito y yo soy esta
jarra imagínense que el caballito está
lleno pero la jarra está la mitad no
técnicamente la jarra tiene muchísimo
más agua que el caballito
yo tendría muchísimo más agua que el
caballito muchísimas cosas pero me
siento vacía porque si falta la mitad de
la jarra de llenar y yo podría comete el
error de pensar que lo que tengo que
hacer es ser como el caballito no
entonces tiro todo el líquido en mí y
jarra y vacío el caballito
quiero pasar con esta jarras hemos
sentido mucho más vacía porque no
funciona así no y al revés también o sea
si el caballito dijera guau quiero tener
tanta agua como la jarra qué pasa si le
echamos toda esta agua el caballito es
demasiada tal vez por tanta presión se
caiga el caballito y se rompa y o por
más que uno sea mejor que otro
el caballito podría tener menos agua o
menos de espacio podríamos decir pero
puede ser un caballito carísimo con
tequila finísimo y vale muchísimo más
que la jarra simplemente somos
diferentes pero hay que dejar de
compararnos hacia abajo y hacia arriba
aceptar mi forma esta soy yo aceptar que
yo soy un caballito carísimo y amar mi
caballito
no primer paso
cuestionar para conocer segundo paso a
aceptar tercer paso ya que sé
ya que sé cuál es mi forma ya me conozco
ya sé que me llena ya sé que soy este
caballito y a mí me llena el tequila ve
a la fuente que te va a dar ese tequila
que haces de la fuente de agua de
jamaica
hizo una facilísimo suena muy fácil pues
ve a la fuente
obvio pero porque justamente a la hora
de la acción no es tan fácil porque
implica tomar decisiones implica salir
de tu zona de confort y volvemos a mi
vida un poco justo yo me empecé a dar a
conocer y me di cuenta que ya no me
gusta ya no me llenaba tener mi empresa
con mis productos implicó una cosa y me
di cuenta que me encantaba es hacer esto
comunicar mensajes
implica un cambio de carrera implica
perder materias
aquí yo soy la persona más feliz del
mundo de estar aquí parada de verdad es
un sueño pero llevo un mes con gastritis
nerviosa y saber que me va a parar aquí
porque implica
vale la pena 100% vale la pena pero
implica
y no sé si se han podido dar cuenta pero
los pasos son medio casos porque no es
tan fácil para los pasados paso tres se
conoce arte si somos honestos creo que
es un trabajo de toda la vida siempre
hay más que conocer de ti
entre más te conozcas más cosas vas a
tener que ir aceptando y vas a tener que
ir cambiando de fuentes porque vas
cambiando y vas creciendo y creo que
este ha sido mi descubrimiento más
grande que al final la plenitud más que
una meta o sea más que cuando yo logré
ser esta persona increíble y tenga 55
mil cosas voy a ser feliz es un camino
es un camino y de verdad los invito a
buscar saciar esa sed que tienen de
plenitud no se conformen con una vida a
medias cuando de verdad pueden vivir en
plenitud y se los digo desde mi
experiencia no de que ya soy la persona
más plena
pero si les aseguro que de verdad soy
mucho más plena de lo que era esa niña
de 15 años buscando respuestas sobre la
felicidad
no se conformen hay respuestas hay agua
para asociar es hacer
atrévanse a buscar atreverse a vivir en
plenitud
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]